あと子だよ
かわいいアサストパチってるし皆さんキーホルダー使ってますかあの僕も限りですね
キーホルダというかストラップとが色々付いてるんですよ
どこ行ったっけな
なくしましたっていうくらいんですねキーホルダー付れてもすぐ泣く子自慢ですよ僕は
塚地馬ねーか二次あまりいいこと雪で皆さんきよ惚れたよくつけてると思うんです
けれどもこういうの見たことありませんでしょうかあのビルキーホルダーですね昔は
これでいろんな人と決闘してきましたーーーこれあると思うんですけどもこれすごい
便利だと思いませんか立って鍵とかつけてたらさーこれってあの鍵開けるとき
おっ
あれこれ伸ばす必要なくねでこれなんで伸びるんだろうこれのめんつゆなっていいだ
けどの日で清めたんですけども
ボカロがこの動画でキーホルダーに無限の可能性を感じていますこのキーワードが僕
無限の可能性があるんじゃないかなと思いまして今回も100円ショップに売ってるの
全部買いまくってきました北の町にある100円ショップのあの音ノーベルの全部買っ
てきました
tana
やって30分30本のこの伸びるキーホルダーを準備しました
伊豆姉あえげつねぇ量だうわーこ jaf は
をやばいこの伸縮10 r 器物切れないから商品化されてるわけでありまして
の罵声もすぎないでたくさんあったらこれをこんなか甘いがいいなんかメットっていう
かこんなんいたみたいにすれば韓服作れるんじゃないかと思いますけどそれも伸縮性の
ふわふわの韓服ができるわけですよねこの日着るだけで今日は反目を作っ
てみようと思いますグライダーっまずこれ多分人は変わるにしなきゃいけないんでそれ
じゃあもうあのこれも必須です乾谷越えて
アメリだ紡いだハンガーが悪いこれぐらいの大図鑑なら多分ちょうどいいはず
とりあえず全部人がってるんですよ馬ってミュージシャン1まとまるできない待って
見えた見えた瓶これを使います安全が太すぎてもうこれがトーンないんでそれだったら
灯籠の火暴を使えばいったけどますこの隙間に超えているって事なきもは人の体重と
いうか重いものじゃないなぜってきました
枝毛あ多分いうほど来ないとちぎれないんで are you このようにこういう
感じでぜんぶつけていきます
やばいな俺その場の音初登録も追求違い
[音楽]
はいこんな感じでございます完璧これをもうないものに感じておぼつなげでこうする
だけで多分もうさー
場所が悪いこれ時代も完璧ですここでよくねー
入ってきたも完全にも総理の方程式が見え外れておりますうんであともう片方にも
ハンガーで同じような造りを作ります
ん体で完成しました
両サイドハンガーで止めて何所にもしたビニール紐2-キーホルダーのフックをかけて
頑丈に固定いたしましたもうまずで寝れそうじゃん
えっ
ん
きちゃうこれを伸ばすとここでもう寝るんじゃないかという僕の発想なんですよ行って
これどうまで伸ばせるだろうそう気になるちょっと伸ばせますどこまで伸びるか
とりあえず白だけど話でもないで癒す
なって助けてくださいますあって結構いそうなのでも
うんちっぱでもだめだ
真鯛けどこういうのが入っちゃう危ないとレジってんだよなんて本当にやばい持って
ください分ですよね
しますすみます待ってお堂の趣旨が変わってくるあの子がありがしたいんですよ
反目したいのにこれだと韓服前に終わっちゃいそうな勢いですくれたけど無理だよ違う
んだ
ハンモック地帯松谷武判僕じゃなくなってしまって
ブーバーれの予想だ
トーンですかこれは一さんに飛んでくれねー
さあっ
[拍手]
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ
今回の失敗の原因はハンガーですハンガーが悪いの城これからすよって意気込んでた
ところで半がたちが伝えなかったところがありますよね非常に残念な結果になって
しまいましたが暗黙は
次回がんばりますすべし